clayne is running the show ron clayne is
the chief of staff and and susan rice is
the
minister of propaganda in the sense that
rice is the ideologue the progressive
ideologue and claine is the
administrator but the most powerful
person in the white house is uh jill
biden
so you don't get to talk to joe biden
unless you go through jillbot very very
close to nancy reagan and i wrote the
book killing reagan and nancy after uh
mr reagan was shot she controlled access
to the president so does jill
now jill looks to me like to be a far
left zealot
she looks like she's right on board with
rice and clayne and all these others
because
i don't see any moderation in that white
house at all
i'm dave rubin and joining me today is
the host of no spin news and the author
of the new book killing the killers the
secret war against terrorists bill
o'reilly welcome to the reuben report
thanks sending me back dave appreciate
it how are you doing bill i'm doing well
i have to tell you as someone that just
got my second book out i am told because
i'm looking at the cover of your book
right now this is your 17th number one
bestseller how many how many books have
you written in the first place
25
a lot of them children's books uh off
the o'reilly factor
but uh all of the killing books have hit
number one and uh the killing series
uh the killing the killers is the
eleventh book in the series the most
successful non-fiction book series of
all time
and that's pretty stunning when you
think about it and humbling for me
for sure what what do you consider
yourself first i mean do you consider
yourself a pundit first or a journalist
do you do you consider yourself a
journalist in a traditional sense or is
it an author first does it matter what's
first
i'm a journalist slash historian
master's degree in
broadcast journalism from boston u
network experience at cbs and abc
seen it all 84 countries so i'm a
journalist first but i bring a
history perspective because i used to
teach high school history so it's an
interesting combination it served me
well so let's uh i want to talk about
the book obviously but let's dive into
just some of the stuff going on right
now obviously as we're sitting here uh
abortion and the reversal of roe v wade
is the big one uh first off are you
shocked that putting aside the decision
that we are not talking about the leak
anymore that that seems to have come and
gone and is sort of irrelevant at this
point or at least in terms of what the
mainstream media will discuss relative
to it
i'm not shocked because you got merrick
garland the attorney general he has no
interest in finding out who leaked that
out
from alito's office garland to have any
interest in finding that out because it
would hurt
but
um
and you have the head of the u.s
marshals service
supervising it no updates no press
conferences nothing and they're just
hoping it goes away i mean look we live
in a country now where there really
isn't a criminal justice system or a
civil justice system for that matter
anymore it's evaporated
now you have little fiefdoms all over
the place and the prosecutor in new york
city doesn't want to uh prosecute
somebody who stabs another person and
he's not going to prosecute
and the governors and the president and
everybody else allows it to happen so
that's where we are
you've been warning about this stuff for
a long time do you ever feel boy i guess
i was right they said a lot of bad
things about me but i guess i was right
about some of this stuff
well when you're right they're going to
say bad things about you dave
that's just the way america works if
you're right you're going to get
hammered i read a book called culture
warrior way back
if you read that book
everything i said in that book and that
was the mid-2000 you know
about 2004 i think
came true
i could see the trend way before it
happened
because what we have is cowardly
politicians
i mean that's what it comes down to
80 percent maybe maybe 70 percent of the
elected people in this country are
cowards
they're not interested in helping the
folks they're interested in maintaining
their power so when you have that
and you have an electorate that's
largely uneducated people don't know
what the constitution is they don't know
what it says they don't care
they want to know
what the latest tweet is or what's on
instagram and they want to spend their
lives here this is where most people
live now right here in this little
machine
i want to take the time to understand
what's happening and why it's happening
and when you get a voting public like
that
you get california you get new york
state you get illinois
and that's what we have
so
it does that what you're explaining
right there really
is the perfect example of what's going
on with the reaction to roe v wade that
nobody really understands this is about
states rights and what is and in isn't
in the constitution and i guess to some
extent a certain set of the society just
doesn't care what's in the constitution
they just want it done their way
well not just a certain portion of
society the speaker of the house of
representatives doesn't care what's in
the constitution
nor does the president of the united
states or the senate majority leader
schumer
you think any three of those care what's
in the constitution everybody knew
ruth bader ginsburg knew
that the 1973 ruling
whereby abortion was legal all over the
united states
wasn't based
on the constitution
because the right of privacy
is never mentioned
now in the criminal justice system
you have a right of sanctuary in your
home
the authorities cannot come into your
home without a warrant without probable
cause
and that happened because the british
the king
they were kicking doors all over the
place so the colonists had no privacy at
all here come the troops boom they'll
take your house
but as far as abortion was concerned was
never mentioned
and because it was never mentioned it
then falls under the tenth amendment as
you know dave and the tenth amendment of
the constitution says if an issue is not
clearly mentioned
in
the writings here
the amendments of the constitution
the states then decided
and that's what happened with roe v wade
so so what do we do what do we do right
now if obviously everyone everyone in my
audience watching this and hearing you
knows that's true but what do we do if
basically half the country and as you
just said a huge portion of the
political leadership simply don't care
about the documents anymore to me this
seems like a completely intractable
impasse you know you can't negotiate
with people that don't think that the
basic founding the basic documents are
good or are worthy of paying any
attention to or abiding by
i agree that you can't negotiate with
someone like nancy pelosi
i mean her own church her own church
can't negotiate with her she wouldn't
show up to a meeting with the archbishop
of san francisco who wanted to discuss
her advocacy for abortion it's more than
i don't want to impose my view of
abortion on others it's way more than
that nancy pelosi wants as many
abortions in this country
as possible
now how you can be a roman catholic and
all that view it's impossible you can't
but she
doesn't care
what the church says
doesn't care what the constitution says
she is in it for power
she understands her base is left far
left she's going to pander to that base
no matter what the issue is
she's like biden
she has no core belief system at all
other than i believe in power and i want
it
so what do you do with these what do you
do in this situation i mean what are
what are we supposed to do we guys like
us what you can do
80 million you just voted for black just
live
yeah i mean look you could move or where
you're going to move florida florida my
friend come on down you're still in new
york
but you're still in the united states
yes this is true
if 80 million people are going to vote
for
a guy like joe biden and believe me if
you go back and you look at what
o'reilly said
in october before the november vote of
2020 i predicted everything that was
going to happen because i knew this man
was not capable of doing the job he
cannot do it
all right and everybody has to
understand that
he cannot do it
and so you're putting an incompetent now
you can say it is mental decline i don't
even get into that i'm not a doctor
but he i saw he couldn't campaign
he couldn't utter a cogent sentence in
the debates and i went
this is trouble
but the populist hated donald trump so
much that they put biden in office and
so now we're all paying a price for that
terrible decision who who do you think
is really running the show i mean it
doesn't seem like you think it's by
plane is running the show ron clayne is
the chief of staff and and susan rice is
the
minister of propaganda in the sense that
rice is the ideologue the progressive
ideologue and claine is the
administrator but the most powerful
person in the white house is uh jill
biden
so you don't get to talk to joe biden
unless you go through jillbot very very
close to nancy reagan and i wrote the
book killing reagan and nancy after uh
mr reagan was shot
she controlled access to the president
so does jill
now jill looks to me like to be a far
left zealot
she looks like she's right on board with
rice and clayne and
all these others because
i don't see any moderation in that white
house at all if you're looking for more
honest and thoughtful conversations
about the media instead of non-stop
yelling check out our media playlist and
if you want to watch full interviews on
a variety of topics check out the full
episode playlist they're both right over
here and to get notified of all future
videos be sure to subscribe and click
the notification bell